here's your
headline Scranton Paper Company Dunder
Mifflin apologizes to valued client some
companies still know how business is
done it's more like the whole
article when should we bring out the
cake 1 or 130 one's good
1:30 I'm sorry are we boring you not
Phyllis
I see the sales department are down
there they're in the engine room and
they are shoveling coal into the furnace
right I mean who saw the movie Titanic
they were very important in the movie
Titanic everyone in the engine room
drowned
okay your ass is on the line Mister so
is mine now I'm going to ask you again
what time did you go home last last
night um
6 of
course something
funny cuz you know what millions of
people die every year from drug
use marijuana leads to crack which leads
to Crystal Meth which leads to
death which leads
to
knock it off I'm conducting this
interview no that's not what you said
when I came in here you said that I was
conducting the interview now exactly how
much pot did you
smoke this is not a joke this is not a
carnival kind of
[Music]
bad what it is I don't mean to be crass
but get prepared to get wet
because God wow there was no double
meaning in
that there wasn't you couldn't even get
through it it's the most horrible thing
I'm so sorry when he came out for soccer
practice I I pinched
him where did you pinch him
where would you like the Rice Krispy
treat Stars they Sugar Plum Fairy wands
Sugar Star Sugar Plum Fairy wands
sugar oh my
God
Phyllis yogurt
container Phyllis yogurt
container I
I promise to give Authority back to you
when this crisis is
over do
it say it
hey turn your head
over
sorry do
it do it hey
Michael
[Laughter]
Dwight question that was funny that was
that was like faulty to was funny
[Laughter]
Dwight
TW well hello
everybody hello
everybody oh man fors Phyllis we gave
you one hell of a wedding shower it was
a golden shower Phyllis we all gave you
a
gold we all came in this room for your
wedding and gave you
a we all came in here and gave you a
golden shower well where's my golden
show this here
Plantation is running low on green BS um
we ain't got no money to pay the people
who sell us the sades and dirt men I
can't do this
Michael
[Laughter]
basically but particular good day hello
Dwight shud Archie bar I'm sorry Archie
bar that's his name
[Laughter]
DWI eat spicy foods what is the opposite
of that make spicy foods come out of her
okay NOP
no eat spicy foods okay okay what is the
opposite of that take spicy foods come
out of her nope okay nope nope we're not
doing that
Pam okay so what is it eat spicy foods
and the opposite of that oh make spicy
poo look I can't legally watch this on
fold it comes dangerously close to
prostitution I want eye contact do you
understand how rare that is in nature
I'm not some farm
animal
hey this here is a Ron test kit okay
I'll be putting them everywhere and
please don't throw these
out this is a raidon test
kit please don't throw these
out see them all over the
office
[Laughter]
you have to have sex with a woman then
sex with a man and then just compare the
two preferably in the same night would
you consider nope taking that bullet for
me
n how do we figure this out well you
just have to sleep with a woman I can do
that and then sleep with them in and
then just compare when you think about
both what are you free
sorry okay well you clearly don't care
so why don't you just leave I would like
to stay this pertains to me I would like
you to leave why don't you go outside
and take a shot of insulin and have a
nap okay why do you always assume I have
diabetes you have a glass of apple juice
and tell me that you don't have diabetes
okay
all right see just the noise you made
when you stood up I
[Laughter]
could hey if Saber truly cared about our
long-term well-being they would set up
hand desanitizing stations hold up
what's a hand desanitizing station B of
dirt okay you understand
oh my
God that's a good impro okay you
understand the more we expose ourselves
to germs the
[Laughter]
stronger we have three sex or or heavy
petting closets one masturbation closet
does anyone have a problem with that yes
gay closet five that wasn't five Clos
that's that that wasn't the problem
three heavy petting closets one
masturbation closet and one gay closet
absolutely yes I don't no problem
everybody happy with the glory hole what
well I heard about it somewhere hly
fifth closet will have a glory
[Laughter]
hole okay who can tell me I'm sorry I'm
sorry did you laugh
osar
[Applause]
bro